hey guys and welcome back to our second
episode of steampunks the show where we
let you know what gems are hidden on
Steam from the last week that you may
not know about my name is Jesse I'm ed
and just a reminder we are trying to
avoid games that you definitely know
about already such as the third Monkey
Island game yeah we're just gonna be
released and also shoutouts to surviving
Mars we don't forget our release yes so
those games you probably already know
about but the four games are gonna tell
you about in today's episode you
probably don't
so um get us started with the first one
alright so the first game I play this
week was synthetic synthetic is a
top-down shooter roguelite set in the
robotic feature of 1985 very good year
it asks the question what if firing a
gun was really hard so like in most
top-down shooters in general it's sort
of like a bullet hell thing that's
wave-based it's a lot of frantic
shooting and trying to keep enemies off
your back and accuracy isn't a big part
of it in synthetic accuracy is very
important you need to use your mouse
cursor and point precisely where you
need to shoot because headshots are a
big part of it so you do double damage
with a headshot and because the heads
are so small you can imagine how precise
you need to be so it can be pretty
demanding add to that the fact that each
gun has recoil so you need to wait
between each of your shots to do the
most accurate damage especially if you
have semi-automatic weapons because
every shot counts and what also helps is
standing still so that's kind of really
out of character for I said genre like
this yeah yeah totally backpedaling all
I kind of stop the game encourages you
to stop and start and on top of that
there's an active reload mechanic where
you have to hit e to ejects your
magazine and then hit R or spacebar to
slam another one in there and then
there's the option of waiting for the
reload to finish or hitting R or space
again at a certain time to finish it
quickly and get a double damage I've
always loved active reloads and I love
complicated reload mechanics there's a
really great game out there called our
receiver which focuses on manual gun
to go check out that one if you have
time but in synthetic it makes for a
really really tense shooter because
you're constantly putting yourself in
danger to line up the most effective
shot you can there's all worth it
because getting kills and especially
getting precise headshots on enemies is
really satisfying because of the visuals
and the audio are spectacular the game
has a really good screen shake when you
fire and when you nail an enemy the bang
is really good and they explode robot
all over the ground and there's this
huge red X that comes up and just feels
really pretty good in true roguelite
style the game's aim is to make it way
through to the exit of these randomly
generated levels killing enemies and
some picking up items along the way you
can upgrade your weapons and you can get
new weapons
there are also multiple classes which is
pretty good I played with the standard
class and the rogue who is a silent
pistol because it's possible to get a
jump on enemies in this game it's not in
early access it's a full release title
and it's really polished and it feels
really good to play it's a 15 bucks ok
well my first game of this week focuses
on something that's probably familiar
aliens invading and trying to take over
the world shrimp show very familiar to
me really familiar happens like every
Tuesday but these aliens in particular
one you'll playing as them even though
they are an alien race and to this super
lazy this is a game called lazy galaxy
where you need to engage in this
audience / idle clicker / strategy game
to help them build a base get minerals
together so that you can research space
travel and then go into space with
spaceships and dominate the galaxy cool
yeah so this is as I mentioned an idol
clicker first and foremost which means
you're literally clicking asteroids
I don't think it's gonna be fun I've
enjoyed an auto clicker in my time yes
sir the main thing you need to do is
gather resources
it's the classic gameplay loop where you
do research so you can get more minerals
so you can get more barrels so you can
do more research you can go to space
go to space you can upgrade all of your
buildings and all of your ships it gets
to a point where as you can imagine
you're just pouring resources into these
upgrades to the point where holding down
shift you can buy ten upgrades at once
these upgrades are really expensive okay
down control you can buy 100 upgrades at
once so you're suppose I have this
running in the background like about
your day basically yeah there's a lot of
an offline there's a big offline element
where you get back into the game and
it's like we collected this for you
while you were gone
so the RTS element is in combat so once
you do build your ships you can take off
into space and that's where there are a
series of space battles so just take
place on a single screen whatever ships
you build you can direct them away from
missiles that are being sent towards you
and you can also do a big box select on
the screen to tell them all of them
attack one person or what have you if
you level your ships enough you can get
special abilities for them the enemies
just keep getting tougher and when you
do get to the point where you get to the
end of the I think it's like 10 or 15
enemy engagements that are included in a
system you go to a new system and you
start it again I think the idle clicker
fans this is a really good one and the
RTS elements change it up just enough
that it stays a little bit more
interesting than what you'd expect
all right so before we started this show
if I saw a game had just come out on
Steam was early access and was full box
I would for sure
ignore it yeah right it's it's something
weird about the way our head assigns the
quality of something with its dollar
value yeah and it goes both ways like
something cheap would be really awesome
or something really expensive could be
really bad but that this next game was
four dollars and just like Cinelli
access you know what I was actually
surprised by how decent it was so this
game is called arm to the gears it's a
3d top-down next shooter which has your
typical dark mechanical future sitting
that the Bell tech franchise had okay so
that's like humic warriors and what I
kind of stuff we've got a primary weapon
and you have an artillery or missile
based secondary weapon and you move
around the map and you find pickups
along the way to both change up your
weapons give yourself more missiles get
jet fuel to do sort of prolonged dashes
and get credits now these credits come
into the other facet of the game which
is construction the goal of each of the
maps is to take all the capture points
on the map but since you're just one
mech you'll shoot your way to enemy base
capture the point by holding it and then
boil up autonomous defenses to protect
it while you are and try and capture the
other points in the map because enemies
who are constantly spawning from the
existing bases are going to try and
reclaim them so it makes for a really
nice sort of strategic back and forth as
you're trying to juggle everything so
moving to a base defending it going up
to try and capture something else you
know going back to the old base and sort
of building up those defenses and
upgrading them so yeah it's like I said
it's an early access and it just came
out this week there are only three
campaign Maps available and they're
pretty straightforward so you can blow
through these all in about 30 minutes
but the developer has said the plan is
to at least one new map per month so I
guess I'll wait and see how that goes
but as it stands for a four buck game I
was pleasantly surprised by this
discovery yeah
like even though the shooting was a
friggin cakewalk I got the coming off
synthetic the like strategy elements
really gave a nice sort of layer to that
and had me thinking about other things
I think this games got a really good
foundation so I think with some
refinements and small maps maybe some
more complex AI it could something worth
keeping an eye on if you're not
immediately interested
following on from that theme I think in
steam you get what you pay for is not
necessarily how it guys and that's very
true for my second game which was free
so I was suspicious as to what I would
be getting it's cold troll as in trauma
without the second a it's a free game
that's been made in RPG maker and I love
off VG maker games so the protagonist is
Mike's mulling
he's your average dude and his life is
crap he has a really average office job
and his bosses really mean to him and he
doesn't really have any friends and
can't be like [ __ ] making friends at
work and stuff is like going to the pits
with his like wife and it's all like a
really big issue and yes I think his
name Mike Smalling is very in Willy
Loman type territory but then things
start to go awry so this kind of is a
psychological horror game with Silent
Hill title 5 yes sir it's really
gruesome and I'll say up front before I
roll too much more of the b-roll this is
really a dull themes there's a lot of
nasty stuff that happens in this game
and it is not suitable for kids and good
lord they have done such a good job with
the sound design it's horrifying you get
phone calls and hear like awful
distorted voices and stuff and basically
he's kind of going crazy falling into
his own memories or lack thereof it's
kind of like is he having a break and
what's going on with that or is this
actually like a heart attack situation
that's going down the narrative really
is intriguing it is basically about the
breakdown of a relationship and
someone's insecurities kind of bleeding
into insecurity in their relationship
and jealousy and paranoia and resentment
and stuff like that and and kind of how
that's infected everything to do with
him as a person and everything to do
with how he has relationships with other
people there are a few different choices
you can make in the game and there are
supposedly multiple endings
although I'm not sure how much they
carry through from decisions you make
during the game or if they're related to
very late game decisions the writing is
surprisingly good like way better than
you
expect for a free off eg make a game
falling into those horror type scenarios
where everything's fine for a few like a
few minutes everything's okay for 10 or
15 minutes and then all of a sudden you
can't get out your front door again or
you exit a room and you end up in like a
horrible like red area and this bloody
footsteps all over the ground and stop
is extremely disconcerting even in a
pixel up eg mecha game yeah it is
interesting it's it's a heavy one but
it's I think it's worth playing alright
well that does if a steampunk episode -
if you think we've missed out on a
really good game this week please let us
know on our Twitter handles I'm at
Edmund Tran thank you so much to
everyone who commented last episode and
said hey I picked up the council and I
never would have unless it was you know
free or something
yeah I picked it up and yeah it's pretty
good I'm enjoying seeing all these
interesting games and having to
definitely we hope you are too and we'll
have four more games next week
so be sure to join us again then Mike
[Music]